- On this episode,
it's a good one.
I like it actually.
That's what this
episode's about.
It's a really solid three
episodes in a row, killer.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them
this is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 227 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
I gotta tell you,
what's today, Wednesday?
- [DRock] Yep.
- Three episodes
in a row, India.
Get over here.
Don't be scared.
I know the table's small of some
weird reason all of a sudden.
- [India] Tiny.
What happened to
your, oh, it was broken.
- It was broken.
It was broken.
You saw that with Simon.
It was a good episode.
A lot of great feedback
from Simon episode, India.
Lot of people were
excited to see you again.
Did you see all
the tweets of like,
"Wait, India still
works at Vayner."
- No.
- People thought you
got fired, I loved it.
- Fired?
- Well, yeah, you'd clearly if you
were not to be anymore it would
be more about you being fired.
- Right.
- Yeah.
Tyler, am I doing
one tomorrow?
- [Tyler] What?
- #AskGaryVee tomorrow?
- [Andy] Yes.
- [Tyler] No.
- No?
- [Tyler] I don't know.
- We go to sneak
one in because
I think I can go
five days this week.
That'd be huge.
- [Tyler] Let's do it.
- Alright, fight for it.
Yes, so all things are good.
I'm very focused.
I feel the shows have
been really good this week.
Like from the
quality of the content.
I don't think I've been as
entertaining but I think that
the answers have been strong.
Obviously, the saltiness, oh
by the way, we have to do one
tomorrow 'cause I have to
make my Jets prediction.
- [Tyler] (inaudible)
- I have a strategy of not
doing predictions this year.
It didn't work week one so
I'm gonna give a protection
tomorrow against
Chris Sacca's Buffalo Bills.
India, let's get into the show.
- [India] Alright.
- Yo.
What's up with the videos?
- Yeah, they're
obsessed with them.
- Who? Do we only
do videos now?
Did we agree to
do that actually?
- [Andy] We've always
tried to aim for more videos?
- Alright, we're gonna do a lot
more videos if you want to get
in the show, use the hashtag
#AskGaryVee and submit
more video questions.
I'm in to it.
- Hi Gary, this is
Jelle from Belgium.
First off, I want to start by
thanking you for putting
out all that content.
I've been an entrepreneur for
over five years now and I feel
like that I am becoming
a better businessman,
a better entrepreneur
thanks to your content and
insight so thank you for that.
This is my question.
I've been working to get with a
few interns for couple years now
and they're always around
21-years-old and I feel that
they're lacking two
important skills.
The first skill is critical
thinking or self-criticism.
They should think about what
should I do first and what next.
Why am I advising this?
Is what I produced
really good enough?
The second skill is
taking ownership.
When all given tasks are
finished do they start thinking
about what the next
best step could be?
Do you have any idea how I,
as a boss, as a guides,
can help them
develop their skills?
Thanks.
- Jelle, listen, I think that
the answer to your question is
the critique that you
are putting on them.
You are critiquing them for
this kind of thoughtfulness,
critical thinking and then
action and taking the initiative
in being on the offense.
My answer to you is you need to
do the same with you as a boss
and you need to audit
yourself to do that.
Meaning there is no reason
that you should be in a scenario
where you're struggling with
21-year-old interns for long
period of time because the
truth is if you put the time and
effort to really audit them and
really spend time with them and
then decide for you whether
you're right or wrong as the
judge and jury, as the boss,
that they're good or they're not
good you could speed up
this process very quickly.
So my answer to you is go deep
and spend more time with them
whether that's virtually
or in reality or in real life
where these interns are.
Figure out if they're good.
Give them very detailed
feedback at scale.
Suffocate all the excuses and
then make a decision whether
that person should be in
your organization or not.
For me, if I wanted to know if
anybody here should be in my
organization or not it would
literally take me two days.
Just make it the
thing you do today.
Today you should decide
if these interns are capable,
have the talent and
the capacity to
deliver on your
expectations or not.
Have you been clear in them
and move forward so I think the
answer to your question is in
the same way that your upset
with them that when
their task is done,
they're not doing
the next thing.
I'm upset with you which is
if you slept last night you
could've allocated some of those
hours to auditing your interns
and giving them clear feedback
and making the decision if you
wanted them here or not.
Let's do it.
- Buster.
- Question for you.
Now I know what you did at
age 12, 13, 14, 15, 16 getting
involved in wine and selling
sports cards but what would you
be doing if it were 2016 and
you were 12, 13,
14 and 15 and 16?
Appreciate your answer,
appreciate everything
you do, thanks.
- Buster, Buster, Buster
honestly what I would tell you
is to give you the answer that
you're looking for which is what
what I do what
should you be doing?
How should you be
thinking about things?
Reverse engineer
your strengths, right?
You like the NBA you should hit
up Dunk first of all and have
him put you on but besides that
I think that you need to figure
out what you're good at and
what would you want to do.
I would basically be
today, I'm trying to think.
There'd be so many
things I'd be doing today.
I give a lot of that advice,
I would've made bank
on Snapchat filters.
I think that one guy who did
the Pokémon GO consulting.
I think that was super smart.
Having the
internet to buy and sell.
I'm a salesman.
Buying and selling, uh, just
buying stuff on you know in Asia
and re-marketing in the US.
I think I'd be doing pretty much
everything I was doing at scale.
So because when
I was growing up
sports cards were
what people collected,
I would just be focused on
whatever that version is now.
Sneakers, I'm telling you right
now, I would be, my stories of
Toys "R" Us and garage sales
would be waking up, you know,
at one in the morning and
standing in line at
a SoHo sneaker
store to get that thing,
flipping like I would
be doing a lot of that.
I think the truth is, Buster,
I'd be focusing on
what I was strong at.
What I think I'm really
good at is buying and selling.
I did that with
stuff my whole life.
Now, I do it with
people's attention and
the end consumer's attention.
That is my strength that
I would double down on that.
You, my friend, need to
figure out what you're best at?
Is that making
content on social media?
Is that being a charismatic
personality that I think was
shining through the question?
Is that being a salesperson,
buying selling stuff?
Connecting with people?
When you're 16 you have time.
Like, Jesus, remember
when you were bored?
Remember when you could do that?
Andy, do you remember when
you're like, "I'm bored."
You don't have that kind of time
when you grow up and so I would
take advantage of that time
because that is the asset.
- [India] That's good.
- 'Member being bored?
- Yeah.
Was good times.
(laughter)
- From Brandon.
- Brandon.
- Hey Gary.
My name is Brandon and
I'm social media manager for a
digital magazine app in
mid-town Manhattan called Zineo.
Looks a little
something like this.
My question for you is how do
we leverage content from 5000+
magazines to throw jabs at
a millennial customer who's
attention is typically
away from magazines?
Thanks so much for your answer.
You keep answering questions,
I'll keep asking them.
- Brandon, I have
a couple things.
One you're avocado ambassador,
I need to figure out
what that means.
You're also a Mets fan but
I didn't see any Jets love and
I'm very concerned that you
might be one of
those rare people that
are Mets and Giant fans
who I hate oh so much.
I didn't fully get the
context of the question.
I'm not sure if you guys got it.
Obviously, you guys picked it.
I didn't fully understand
what the objective
was of the magazines.
Was he referring to how we
make micro digital context that
actually gets people to
care about a magazine?
Meaning like buying a
subscription to a mag,
I mean actually I'm very
curious while we're here,
where is your
magazine life right now?
Andy K?
- [Andy] Zero.
- Zero?
- [Andy] 100%
- [Gary] Nothing.
- Nothing.
- [Gary] Zero.
- Zero.
- [Gary] Dunk?
- 5%.
- [Gary] What magazine
would you consume?
- Back home from Sweden.
- [Gary] Swedish
magazines that you read?
- Fashion magazines, yeah.
- [Gary] That you'll at?
- Look and read.
- [Gary] So that comes to
your home and you'll do that?
- Yes.
- [Gary] And that's 5% of your
world you think is your gut?
- 2.5, yes.
- [Gary] 2.5, got it.
DRock?
- [DRock] None.
- Zero.
Other Tyler?
- [Other Tyler]
Maybe like 2 or 3.
- Like what do you consume?
- [Other Tyler] Like photography
and design
magazines a little bit.
- You'll flip
through it a little bit.
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- How about compared
to 24 months ago?
Even less?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah, even less.
- Dunk, compared to 24
months ago even less?
- [Dunk] Same.
- Same. India?
- I subscribe to a couple.
- [Dunk] No, less.
- Less. Less. India?
- Same, a couple.
- What do you have?
- The New Yorker and
then like an art magazine.
- Playgirl?
- No.
(laughter)
Why do you tease me?
- 'Cause I like you.
So, the New Yorker?
- Yes.
- And do you read that?
- Yeah.
- And, it's not just collecting.
Do you think you read as much
New Yorker today as you did
24 months ago? 36 months ago?
- The same.
- 'Cause there's a
scenario where you like it.
Like, weekend morning
coffee kinda thing or?
- Subway magazine.
- Perfect subway
magazine, got it.
Look, I think, that's obviously
a small focus group,
(Gary stammering)
and I don't know Brandon so
that where I'm gonna have to go.
If you're talking about the
notion of what kind of content
can we put out, jabs, in an
ecosystem that is going to get
millennial's excited about then
going in to the magazine world
and subscribing to a magazine,
I think it's a lost cause.
I really do and I think the
magazines that have anybody's
attention right now, I bet you
if we could take these three
wonderful people's brains and
put them here and dissect how
they cared about the
photographer magazine,
the New Yorker and these Swedish
magazines it had a lot more to
do with those brands did to them
10, 15 years ago
and that's the problem.
They thought those were cool
magazines when they
were in junior high.
They were around in the house.
The New Yorker
is an iconic thing.
I think it's a very difficult
proposition and as digital and
mobile devices have become
more magazine-ized
A.K.A. photos have become such a
foundation of the way we consume
the internet versus written
words of a decade ago
I think you're fighting an
uphill battle, my friend.
- Sometimes you got to
hear that, you know?
- Yeah, just yeah.
- Hey Gary.
I'm Sam I'm from Nigeria,
I'm living in San Francisco--
- He said I'm soft.
- And my question for you is
were you too soft to start a
mobile development agency, brah?
Was that too hard for you, blah?
(laughter)
- [India] Brah!
- That's amazing.
I love that whole, are
you, do you lift, bro?
So did he say am I too
soft to start a mobile?
- [India] Development agency.
- I want to say, I want to fight
you is really what I want to do
but I think, yeah, I mean, look,
to answer it in a straight way the
reason building a development
shop in a genre is not
interesting to me is that if
I was to build
a development shop
in a meaningful way, right
now, I would build a messenger
development shop way before
I'd build a mobile
app shop, brah.
Because I don't care about 2016
legacy software.
To me, the reason I built the
company I built is that, unlike,
a VCR or a video game console or
a cell phone or virtual reality,
messaging is tried-and-true.
The mechanism that delivers
it gets killed eventually.
Right?
So the guy caveman Rick
who took a rock and
carved it into the
cave he was messaging and
communicating, right, but the
platform of the day, where the
eyeballs were, were inside the
cave and the smoke signals and
the written word and a telephone
and a television and a movie
theater and a cell phone and a
VR world and apps within cell
phone and so brah, the reason
I didn't go with a mobile
developing shop is it was just
too small and I needed to
win the communication game
infrastructure that I can deploy
against any mechanism that
delivers the story, brah.
(laughter)
- Every episode we have to have
a question that gets
you a little fired up.
- You found it.
That's awesome, by the
way, thanks for the question.
- GaryVee!
What's happening, man?
My name is Bo Muchoki.
I'm a real estate agent and
a motivational blogger and
I have a question for you
about self-awareness.
You've spoken a lot
about this topic and
how to gain self-awareness.
You've also touched on how
meditation is a trend that's
really gonna take over and be
in every household in the near
future so what are your thoughts
on how to gain self-awareness
through meditation.
I, myself, gained a lot of
self-awareness and clarity on
who I am and what my actual
goals are through meditation so
what are your thoughts on how
meditation can help you
gain self-awareness? Thanks.
- Bo, thanks for the question.
I think the answer is,
I believe.
I believe I believe you.
There'd be no reason for you
to make this video and lie.
I believe that there's a lot of
people that are gonna gain it.
I'm a very, very, very strong
advocate for way more discovery
by the human race around
understanding the brain and
mental health, mental fitness,
mental, mental, mental.
I promise you that when it's all
said and done for me people will
realize that that was
the game that I won.
That that's the
gift that I was given.
That that was where
I had all-time skills.
It's just we've grown up
in a world and I,
for the last 40 years, where
that wasn't the conversation.
People can tell if you're
pretty or good at athletics.
Nobody rolled up
on me and were like,
"Yo, bro your brain
is on point." Right?
I'd say that because when I say
brain I mean the mental pillars
of emotional intelligence that
are the foundation of everything
I've been talking
of last four years.
You could tell me
I'm good at school.
Memorizing something
and regurgitating.
That's not what
we're talking about.
It's having that centering,
having that place, that energy
that allows you navigate
through all adversity.
Not getting too
high in your highs
and not getting too
low in your low.
It's balance.
It's the contradictions
that make me me.
I want awesomeness for everybody
but I want to punch all of you
in the face too because if
you want to compete with me,
you're gonna lose and
it's all that stuff.
Sorry, India.
And that's all that stuff and
so it's all of that foundational
stuff that we need
a lot more for and
if meditation through a
process is what unlocks
people to be happier,
to be more grateful,
to deploy more empathy
to do all the tried and true
cliché things that would make
the world awesome, awesome
then we would be in a
really, really good spot.
And I don't believe that there's
Nirvana and it's gonna be
perfect but moving anything
just a little bit really works.
We've had world wars.
We've had in epidemics.
We've had enormous atrocities.
We continue to do
them in the world today.
There's genocide and
people are confused and
so yeah I'm I'm all
'bouty, 'bouty, I don't even
know why I said that but I was
thinking about
Master P the other day.
I'm all about, all about
people understanding that mental
health, meditation all these
things have a lot of upside and
that we do not understand
anything about
the brain currently.
Just an enormous, vast
opportunity for us over the next
century to learn more about this
and I'm excited and grateful
that my great, great, great,
great-grandchildren will live in
a world where that will be
understood far more
in a substantial way.
In the way that people died
from disease that we so easily
navigate through today,
all these unhappy people,
and all these tragedies,
and all these negatives
that are completely,
completely coming from the fact
that the mental status of that
person isn't in the best place
it could be are gonna be an
amazing challenge for our race,
for our world, for who
we are as humans.
And I'm really into it and
I really bank that that is where
so much of my
happiness comes from.
I'm actually quite sad that I'm
not to be able to see it where
it's gonna be 100 years from
today unless somebody figures
out technology and I'm into it.
I'd be pumped to be a buck 40.
I will Yoda this
fuckin' world up.
And so that's that.
- [India] "I will Yoda
this shit up" as a t-shirt.
- I would love to
look like Yoda.
- [India] So not how long he
lived, just what he looks like?
- The punchline there is like if
you told me I could live to 840
and it would be like Yoda or
Crane from
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
where I'm just
a brain in a machine but
I know what's up,
I'd be into that.
- [India] Either option or
you want Yoda over the brain?
- Well I'd probably take Yoda
only because he's still like a
complete thing and bad ass
cane I'd be like, "Hey, India."
You know?
Yeah, you're still there.
Yeah, you're still around.
- That's everything.
- We'll because if I figured
it out, I'd pass it on to you.
- Oh! Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I'd prefer you'd live.
- Oh, that's nice.
- Yes.
Question of the day, this is
actually an interesting question
because I actually think this
last little rant is
not for everybody.
If you could control it,
if I told you,
"Pssst, weird thing,
India is a genie from the future
"and can make anything happen."
In the comments section and just
go, you can justify, you can do
whatever you want but just a
number's fine by me if you could
control it at what
age do you want to die?
How long do you want to live?
What number?
Andy?
On the spot,
let's go, quick. Let's go.
- 120.
- [Gary] Dunk?
Infinity is the only
non-answer allowed.
- 140.
- [Gary] 140.
- [Dunk] Yeah.
- Other Tyler?
- [Other Tyler] 150.
- [DRock] At least 500.
- I'm like 100.
- 100.
Yeah, you're so, you're so that.
I would've bet the farm on that.
You're counter-culture.
You're like, "Oh, I don't know."
Mine's, I think
mine would be 888.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
- (hip hop music)